Really excited to introduce
you to Emily calendar.
Emily Emily is a correspondent
on Netflix's to Menuso.
Bill Nye saves the world.
She's a producer and the host of
foxes exploration outer space.
She also covers the space industry as a
writer for tech crunch and has been on
the Ted Stage Multiple Times.
Through our work,
Emily seeks to explain science
related topics in an easy,
digestible and entertaining way to
increase stem literacy and in the general
public and to inspire more
women to pursue stem careers.
Please welcome Emily to Google.
Okay.
All right.
So before talking about how you discovered
a passion for space exploration,
let's start with why space
exploration is so important.
What's your elevator pitch
to skeptical politicians?
Yeah, so it's hard to make an
elevator pitch for this, right?
I get this question a lot.
It's the most popular question.
Usually it's stated as more
of an argument. You know,
why are we spending so much money on
space exploration when we have so many
problems down here on earth?
Um,
and I usually skip the traditional
arguments of, uh, you know,
there's thousands of NASA spin offs.
There's a lot of great commercialize
technologies we've gotten out of NASA
research and development. Um,
or the fact that, you know,
how would you live your life
without a space based technology,
without satellites, without gps? Because
I think those arguments are overstated.
There are there,
there said a lot and we've become numb
to them and they haven't convinced
everybody yet.
So instead what I like to start off
with is trying to understand what we're
actually talking about here.
Um,
how much money is actually spent
on space exploration, right? Uh,
so NASA gets $19 billion a year and
if you think of the federal budget,
the total federal budget as $1,
then NASA allocation of
that dollar is half a penny.
So it's a relatively small piece of
the pie, but it's still $19 billion.
That's a lot of money.
We should be able to have a great
justification for spending it on space.
Um, for example, I,
I think Google's earnings last
year were about $20 billion.
So if Google wanted to, they could
fund the entirety of NASA. Um,
that's a good perspective. Yeah. But
it's still a lot of money, right?
So that even out of that $19 billion,
half of the money at NASA is spent purely
on science efforts on studying climate
change on setting solar,
whether that, you know,
the sun emits radiation towards the
earth and that can be very harmful to our
national assets in space to gps,
things like that.
Half of the budget is spent
on education and on aviation.
We often forget about that
second or that first a in Nasa,
the National Aeronautics
and Space Administration,
NASA is doing a ton of work on
developing planes that can be a more fuel
efficient, more cost effective and
fewer emissions, things like that.
So we're really talking about
the other half of NASA's budget,
the $8 billion or so spent
on human space exploration,
the traditional rockets they sending
humans to the ISS, going to Mars,
that kind of stuff.
So it's an even smaller piece of an
already small piece of that Pie. Um,
but when I,
theoretically if I'm talking to a policy
maker and trying to justify that money
for space exploration, I like to
talk about the three g's. Gold,
glory and God.
And those are often used,
the often used as the three justifications
for early European explorers to
explore the new world. They were
there incentives, they're motivators.
And for us, I think it's very
similar for space exploration.
Those are similar incentives that we
should use for space exploration for gold.
Nearly every resource that we have
here on earth is available and nearly
limitless quantities and outer
space, right? And so there's,
there's already a few private companies
working to mine asteroids and harvest
those resources.
And there had been prominent entrepreneurs
who have said the first trillionaire
will be made in space.
And if you're a policy maker,
you have to think which nation do you
want to be in control of those resources
ultimately. And then with glory, uh,
ultimately there will be a flag placed
on Mars. And where do you want that flag?
It'd be from,
because there are many players
in the space industry that
are working to do that.
You know, China and all of
Europe and Russia and India,
they have great space programs and one
of them is going to be the first person,
the first nation to land to human on
Mars. And then with God, you know,
with the early European explorers,
they felt like they had a moral obligation
to spread Christianity. But with,
with space exploration,
I think we can think of that in a
more broader context of culture.
And when there is theoretically,
ultimately a colony on Mars,
what culture do you want them to have?
What government do you
want them to set up?
What civil rights do you
want them to implement?
And if you're the first person there,
you have leverage to dictate
how that all plays out. Um,
and then the last justifications that I
give to everyone that I think are even
more important is a national security
and the survival of the human race just
to, you know, put it lightly. Uh,
because 99.9% of all species that have
ever roamed the earth have gone extinct.
And none of them, to my knowledge,
have had space programs, right?
They didn't have the ability to check the
climate and see how it's changing over
time and figure out where in the earth
they should live to avoid extreme
climate.
They didn't have the ability to track
asteroids or they certainly didn't have
the ability to have the technology to,
uh,
to move an asteroid away from arts path.
Um,
and Elan Musk always uses the analogy,
you know,
setting up a human colony on Mars is like
backing up the human race on a Martian
hard drive.
And I think those above all are some
of the more long term really powerful
justifications for space exploration.
So you've had a, I'm sure you've had a
chance to take their message directly to,
to some political leaders.
Do you find that your argument
is persuasive or does it get a,
and that you can break through by framing
it in a different way like you just
did or there's some just huge barriers
to understanding that that issue?
Yeah,
I think it's hard to understand the
really important justifications like the
survival of the human species because
that's not likely to happen in the next
four years. During their
next election, right?
They have to think election to
election. They have to get, uh,
their job in the next four
years. And it's hard to, uh,
make decisions based on something that
could potentially happen decades or
hundreds of years from now.
So you've had the cup, I'm going to
combine a couple of questions here.
You've had,
if you've had a both at NASA
and with a political leader,
what did those two internships earlier
in your career teach you about the
workings of Nasa,
a gum or organization?
Politics. Yeah, so this,
this is really interesting. So, um,
I have learned from those
experiences that when Nasa,
NASA is often criticized
for being inefficient or
that a lot of their projects
run over budget and over schedule.
For example,
eight years ago during
the Bush administration,
we were going to the moon through
a program called Constellation,
but for a number of reasons, the
program was over budget, over schedule,
and for a number of other reasons,
when Obama came to office,
he cancelled the program
and said, you know what? No.
Instead we're going to
go on a journey to Mars.
That program was really inefficient.
We're going to do our own thing. Um,
and it speaks to the sort of,
uh,
political instability of a NASA
program over time because when a new
administration comes in,
they have their own ideas on what they
want to do with the space program and
NASA,
I think it's a lot of unfair criticism
on that because when Congress gives them
an engineering challenge, like we, we,
we want to go to Mars in
the next 15 to 20 years.
They want to go back to their desks
and figure it out and find the best
technologies to do that.
But then in addition to that
problem, congress is like,
but also the congressman from Alabama
has a factory that builds rocket engines
and you need to use his rocket engine
because they want to keep all those people
employed. And also the congresswoman
from California, very powerful.
Congresswoman wants to have her
rocket assembly line kept in play.
And so you have to make the maximum
diameter of the booster of the big rocket.
Bayer is going to bring the humans
to Mars B, you know, this big. And,
uh,
then NASA is working under these very
ridiculous restraints on optimizing this
already very difficult
engineering problems.
So it's no wonder why things ultimately
become over budget and over schedule and
it's to it,
it sort of speaks to why it's so difficult
to ever implement a program to get to
Mars.
Cool.
Want to go run back down to,
uh,
before you got into college because some
of the people watching this will be in
high school and wrestling through
her parents of high schoolers.
So you've spoken about not
being surrounded by a lot
of stem role models growing
up. How did you make the decision
to pursue a degree in engineering?
What led to that?
Yeah,
I,
so I wasn't one of those kids when I
was little that always wanted to be an
astronaut.
I liked space,
but it wasn't something
that I was obsessed with.
Like a lot of my peers in
the space industry. Um,
I liked math when I was in high school
and I googled careers that would make a
lot of money after college and across
the board, they're all engineering,
right? And so I was like, I liked math.
Engineering uses math and they make
a lot of money. And so I honestly,
that is how I chose to go into
engineering. But engineering is hard.
It's very time consuming. A lot of
people leave engineering once they start.
So what kept me in engineering was
because there are more opportunities for
students who pursue stem careers, uh,
and more interesting opportunities,
more paid opportunities, more
opportunities to travel. Um,
then I would argue any other, uh,
a major that you could choose.
For example, when I was in stem, I
did as a student, I was 21 years old.
I think I wrote the vomit comet.
I did an internship in China.
I was paid to do, you know,
speak at conferences and Italy.
Like all of this stuff was,
was things that I was able to do were
things that I was able to do because I was
in stem and I didn't see my friends
who are pursuing other majors, uh,
able to do things like that.
So maybe drilling down at, I mean,
engineering is such a broad terms.
So let's drill down an
aerospace engineering.
So for a student that's never heard that
term before, but her baby is hurting,
this curious,
bringing that terminal,
like what does it actually mean
to be an aerospace engineer?
Yeah, so it's, it's Arrow and it
space. So if you go into aerospace,
you either like planes, helicopters,
missiles or rockets. Um,
and, uh, the people that
that go into that major,
they typically leave and they work at
NASA or they work at one of NASA's primary
contractors, uh, for industry.
They work at the Boeings or the
north of [inaudible] of the world,
or they work in the really new and
exciting sector of private space. Uh,
and the private space industry like space
x or blue origin and virgin galactic,
um, or they go and serve in the military
at the air force or the navy. Um,
or they work for the Department of
Defense or the CIA or something like that.
Yeah, there's private space industry.
Just to pivot off that w, what,
what effect has that had on aerospace and,
and the opportunities to do
new and innovative things?
It's a bit of good thing.
Has it been a bad thing?
It's been somewhere in the middle.
Um,
like so touching on what I said before
about the NASA having all of these
restrictions on how to implement the best
solution to this engineering problem a
lot,
I mean the private sector certainly does
have their own restrictions like making
a profit, which is a different type of
restriction, but they don't have the, the,
the, the congressional restrictions
that NASA does so they can innovate in a
different way, which I
think is, is really great.
And a Elon Musk came up with the
interplanetary transit system recently,
which was a really innovative cost
effective approach to go to Mars and is
different than a lot of what
NASA had proposed before.
So I think that is disrupting kind of
our approach to innovation in the space
industry.
That kind of leads right into
my next question, which is,
so the Fox series that you a host
and produce exploration outer space,
there was an episode focused on Mars.
So having a,
I mean I know there's a lot that goes
into creating an episode like that,
that the, that you don't see when
you watch it. Great show by the way.
He strongly recommended,
um, the, uh, what did,
what did you learn about how realistic
it is for us to conceive of having any
kind of colony on Mars in our
lifetimes or children's lifetimes?
Yeah,
it's going to be really difficult.
The cost I think is the,
is one of the primary factors of that to
the lowest number I've seen on a round
trip mission to Mars for one round
trip mission leading up to all the
technologies you need, um,
is $30 billion. Yeah. Right.
And if we're going to go to Maurice,
we would probably want to do something
similar that we did with the Apollo
program.
You don't want to just go once,
you want to go multiple times
and if you're really ambitious,
you want to build a colony there.
Um,
but the minimum number of people that you
need to build a genetically stable and
healthy colony and a new
area is 40,000 people.
Interesting. Yeah, it's sort of a
rabbit hole I went down recently,
like how many people do
actually need so that, you know,
it's like not incestuous and
in 40,000 is a lot of people.
That's a lot of trips to Mars.
That's a lot of $30 billion trips to Mars.
So that in itself makes it really,
I don't want to say unrealistic,
but a really difficult challenge,
especially when you consider, uh,
the political sustainability
of NASA programs.
I mean there's rumors that with
the incoming Trump administration,
they may want to go back to the moon
and scrap a lot of stuff that we've gone
that we've already built,
uh, to going to Mars.
So it's hard to keep on
track to one destination and,
you know, be being able to afford those
trips is, it's just a whole another beast.
So I wanna circle back to something that
you said earlier about the vomit comet.
Um,
I've always wondered this,
I still kind of crocket are you actually
wait lists or is it just feel like
you're weightless cause you're
still the gravitational force.
Are you high enough?
Like what?
What is it as sensation of weightlessness
or is it technically wait lists?
I'm old.
Yeah, so you're weightless relative
to the airplane. Got It. Right. So,
so the airplane is diving down toward
the ground and you are both in a free
fall,
so you're free falling within a plane.
It's kind of like if
you were in an elevator,
they cut the cables and you both
started free falling towards the ground,
you would feel weightless within
the elevator. So that's exactly the,
the plane flies and parabolic motion
like this and it's essentially a 10,000
foot roller coaster.
And when it's diving toward the ground
and your falling within the aircraft,
that's when you feel about
30 seconds of weightlessness.
Yeah. That, that weightlessness.
If you were in a,
you basically in a constant free
fall and when you're in orbit and it
physiologically different,
in other words,
when you're waiting
list the space station,
are there different physiological effects
then when you're in the vomit comet
for that little window of time?
It's so it's the same feeling,
but the physiological effects I think
become problematic when you're in that
period for a longer period in 30 seconds.
There's a lot of fluid issues,
especially fluid in your brain.
They have a lot of vision
impairment issues because
you're the fluid inside your
body acts a little bit different under
extended periods of weightlessness.
If you're looking for
gifts for the holidays,
vomit comet on my wishlist
or at the head of these days,
low,
low price of 6,000
a little little, little more attainable
than the mission to Mars. Yeah,
that's true. Relative to your cool factor,
you get to work with
Bill Nye the science guy,
probably one of the ultimate science
communicators and a role model for me.
So what can you share about your role
on bill? Nice upcoming Netflix series.
Yeah,
so he has a new show that's going to be
airing on Netflix in the spring called
Bill Nye saves the world and I
am one of five correspondence.
So if you imagine what
the daily show was like,
they have field court or is like they
have field correspondence that go out and
do different stories or segments.
And so I'm one of the correspondence,
Derek Muller of potassium,
youtube severity. Tassian he's another
one. Then there's two comedians, uh,
Joanna Hausman and then Nazeem Hussain
who's from Australia and then Karlie
Kloss,
the supermodel slash Victoria secret
model slash advocate for coding.
So yeah, so it's a really
great, smart, funny,
super talented group of people
that I get to work with.
And we each have tackled two to three
different stories in different countries
around the world. Uh, and then the show,
we'll be talking about the stories that
we've done and then bill and I will do a
lot of experiments and bits and they have
a lot of really amazing guest stars on
the show.
So I think I'm,
what I'm really excited about with this
show is that I personally think that it
can do what the daily show did
for politics, which was, you know,
politics can be confusing and sort of
annoying and sometimes very boring.
And I think science in many ways
can be similar. And I'm hoping that,
and I believe that this show can
do the same thing for science.
Cool. Well, another initiative,
if you didn't know enough on your
plate is you recently announced,
which I picked up just a
couple of days before this,
is that you're working
in a chapter book series,
Simon Kids to bring a love of
science and tech, the girls.
Tell me a little bit about the series
and the first book, Ada lace on the case.
Yeah,
so this is in general,
I have this chapter book series that's
meant for third graders and it's called
Ada lace,
a nod to Ada Lovelace that what many
people consider the first computer
programmer. Um, and I,
I wanted to do something like this
because representation in stem is so
important and there's not that many books
out there with strong female leads who
have a knack and an interest
in science and technology.
So Ada lace is the main character.
She's a third grader with a
knack for science and tech.
She loves building gadgets and robots
and she uses her inventions to solve
mysteries and solve problems.
Cool.
It sounds like a partners with Goldie
blox would fit into the words there at
some point. This very similar, very cool.
Engineering has a reputation of being
one of the harder decrees to tackle.
And you mentioned that,
that it's,
it's tough and some people
don't make it through.
What advice do you have for surviving
and thriving in an engineering program?
Yeah, so I, I will say that, uh,
when I was younger I didn't consider
myself one of the smart kids.
I was more of a slow learner and I was
very intimidated by the topics of science
and engineering and all of that.
And so I get it.
I understand how it's very intimidating
because it was very intimidating to me.
But I will remind people that there's
a lot of time in the day, yes.
That you can work to make yourself
smarter about on various topics.
We waste a lot of time watching
Netflix and on social media.
And so there's a lot of time in the day
to make yourself be better at at certain
topics.
And I've learned that personally because
I wasn't one of the smart kids and I
had kind of tried to work
my way up to becoming one.
Yeah,
that's actually the follow the next
week you didn't consider yourself one of
those markets yet.
You got a Ford Auto and in college and
you've got through a very tough part and
then went on to get a
master's degree in a way.
Do you think that that maybe it helped
that you didn't have the arrogance of I'm
the smart kids and you felt
you had to work really hard or,
no, I, I,
that's hard because confidence can be
really helpful in certain situations.
It can make you sure of yourself,
but in the same way knowing that you
don't know everything makes you always
check your sources,
always check your answer and make sure
that you're always studying a little bit
harder than maybe you
need to. Uh, so having,
being humble about your own
intelligence is probably helpful.
Cool.
Uh,
what's the most common misperception
about engineering that you find yourself
correcting other than engineers? Drive
trains. Yeah. He's still here though.
Yeah, that's it. Go on for little kids.
When we go and talk to little kids
about joining stem fields, the,
the narrative that's often told is,
you know, you can be part of, of the,
the generation that shapes the future.
You can build the next Tesla,
you can build the next a rocket.
You can do work on iPhones and all of
these tech gadgets that we work with every
day.
But I don't often hear the narrative
that you can use these skills to help the
world do.
You can use the skills to not just make
it cool and fun and interactive to, to,
uh, you know, virtual
reality and things like that.
But you can do it to help people
less fortunate than yourself.
And I like speaking about that side of
engineering engineers without borders,
for example, which was something I was
active in when I was an Undergrad. Um,
because I think that speaks really loudly
to kids who want to help the world in
some way. And if you can tell them that
stem will give them specialized tools.
Did you that I think that can make
it sound really, really interesting.
Well, it's, it's, it's a giving time
of your engineers without borders. Um,
tell me a little bit about that.
I'd actually had heard of that before.
Yeah. Oh, and this is an
incredible organization.
So it's a student run organization,
uh, Thor, I believe it's under,
I participated in it
and it as an Undergrad.
So maybe it's also for Grad students,
but you,
you find engineering problems in,
in developing countries or in,
in areas that that are in need and you
can apply engineering solutions to them.
So for example,
we sent a group of students to Nicaragua
to build a water filter made out of
sand because when it's a,
they always had these really interesting
engineering problems. So this,
this village in Nicaragua,
there was a school where
kids were constantly getting
sick because their water
was contaminated with fecal matter
with waste, things like that.
And the kids were getting really sick and
some of them were dying every year. Um,
and you can't just build
the infrastructure for an
elaborate water filtration
system that we have here, right?
That that's unsustainable.
So instead we built a water filter made
out of sand because a wet sand has these
wonderfully magical properties that
there's a bio layer that exists on the top
of wet sand that can kill
many types of bacteria,
including fecal matter bacteria.
And if you pour wastewater on
top or contaminated water on top,
it's like just a huge bucket of
sand out the other end comes,
uh, clean water, potable water to
drink, cause the sand itself acts as a,
a mechanical filter.
And then the,
the biolayer on top kills a lot of the
fecal matter bacteria or kills the fecal
matter of bacteria.
Very cool.
Well,
I got a few more questions then I'll
open it up to the audience and I'll check
the dory. So, um,
you noticed that you noted in a recent
interview that it was once you get to
college, you kind of looked around
and were, where are all the girls?
What are your strategies,
what were your strategies for
success in that environment?
And then I'll pivot to more
what we can do about it.
But first what we just strategies for
getting through and graduating and not
being one of the statistics.
It didn't,
yeah, I, you know,
I don't know that I have a lot of
good advice for that because it's,
it's not easy and it's,
it's a little bit uncomfortable.
I always try to turn the situation
on my guy friends and imagine,
you know what if you
had no preconceptions,
preconceptions about engineering
before you got there,
and then when you got into your first
class, it was filled with all girls.
It was a total girl club
and you're the only guy.
It would be kind of off putting it, make
you feel a little bit uncomfortable. Um,
but if you really like the
topic, you, you deal with it,
you cope with it and you become like what?
I became a guy's girl.
All of my friends were guys.
Um,
I would tell other girls to make sure
that they are making in sustaining strong
female friendships because those are
absolutely necessary through life.
And they are hard to make
if you're pursuing stem.
So you have to be more proactive
about it then, um, then maybe your,
your male peers. Um, but for me, that's,
that's been one of the ways that I've
remained sane through my career. Um,
and it's absolutely necessary.
Cool. Well, on the positive side,
what have you found to be
the most impactful when
speaking with groups that are
underrepresented in stem?
For me,
it's always about representation.
I always introduce if parents are trying
to make science and tech sound more
interesting to their kids who
may be a minority or a girl.
I showed them role models who are in
stem that may look like or come from the
same community or whatever,
like their kid.
Because you can talk about the same
things. Science is interesting.
Science is great.
Science can help the world.
But when it comes from somebody who
looks and sounds a little bit like you,
the message, uh, rings louder
and it feels more relatable.
So I always try to find
people on Youtube or,
or good books or good toys that have
role models that look like their kid.
Just to wrap up with a
couple more. So the, uh,
you've spoken in Ted talks and others
about stem literacy, which is, uh,
when we started talking about politicians
and how to articulate to them why is
stem literacy going to be
so important going forward,
not just for our political leaders,
but the population as a whole.
And maybe describe what
you mean by stem literacy.
Yeah,
so similar literacy for me,
it's any time there is a science
related issue that affects your life
personally.
So things like genetically modified foods
or climate change or net neutrality,
basically it's anything that sounds
really scary and complicated,
but with a little bit of
knowledge of science and tech,
you can understand the situation better.
And I think it's so critically important
because I haven't checked the recent
congress,
but the last congress,
there were fewer than 7%
of our representatives who
had a formal background in
stem.
And when we're talking about
issues like net neutrality,
that is so scary to me
because if or you know,
or genetically modified foods or climate
change or basically, you know, uh,
self driving cars or drones
that deliver packages,
things like that,
we need policy makers to science and
technology and if our policy makers don't,
then our citizens must.
Very cool.
Just to close,
so imagine you're speaking to a
room full of a high school girls.
What advice do you have for them as
they think about college and beyond?
With my frame of reference with stem,
the best advice I give to
girls is to lift each other up,
lift other girls up. Because when an
engineering, if you're the only girl,
you have this,
this feeling throughout college or Grad
school or even your career that you're
the token girl in any given group,
you are one of one girl or two girls
in any situation that you were ever in.
And so if all of a sudden you're in
a group with, uh, multiple girls,
you have a natural instinct to
want to be competitive with them.
So I try to tell them to fight that
instinct because life will be a lot better
and a lot happier if you
are lifting each other up.
Um, you talked about, uh, role
models and mentors. When you're,
um, meeting with people who
are underrepresented in stem,
how about for yourself?
Have you found good role models and
mentors or do you feel like you're
trailblazing and kind of
figuring it out by yourself?
I, there's always someone
I'm looking up to. I mean,
it's hard to find people that I,
I see exactly myself in,
uh, I mean my role models are
bill Nye, Neil degrasse Tyson,
people who are a great storytellers
and also really effective and efficient
science communicators. That combination
of skills I think is, is really unique.
And I find it in people who are on Youtube
and people like Neil degrasse Tyson
and uh, and Bill Nye. So those are
my role models even at, for me,
it's hard to find,
um,
women in this science communicator
role who are much, uh,
you know, more into their career. I have
peers that I look up to who are, you know,
at the same stage that I am.
Um,
and I think that's fine to
have a role model that's,
that's your friend as well cause you
can always learn from each other.
So a question from the virtual viewers is,
you've already mentioned
the volume of content.
What's the coolest thing
that you've gotten to get
exposed to through either the
programs you've done or internship with
NASA in the space field as a result of
this opportunities you've had?
Uh, well working with they'll
NYSE hands down the coolest.
All right. What makes them so cool? I'm
that everything you've already said, this
is exactly as you would expect.
He is,
he's somebody who has been in this field
for so long and has incredible science
stories that I imagined him
as sort of a, you know, your,
your uncle or your grandpa that has a
million stories to tell and just will go
on and on and on telling really
fascinating stories. But you know,
it's just somebody that will ramble
about science for as long as you will let
him.
And He,
it's so endearing that he is something
that he genuinely cares about and is
really excited to talk about.
So I love that with my show. Um,
I've, you know, anytime I get
to fly, I'm really excited.
So I interviewed Dick Rutan recently who
was the famous test pilot who flew the
first nonstop flight around the world on,
on fueled nonstop flight with voyager.
And Dick Rutan is part
of the, uh, aviation duo.
His brother is Burt Rue Chan,
who built actually designed spaceship
one that's in the hallway out there. And,
uh,
Burt Rutan designed voyager.
And I was interviewing Dick Rutan and
he was talking about that nonstop flight
around the world. And, and I asked
him, what was your expectation,
what like was it as just as good as you
expected? And he started to tear up.
And it was one of those emotional
moments that was the last milestone in
aviation.
And I was talking to the man who
achieved it and he was getting emotional
telling the story and
that was so powerful.
And then after that we flew in,
um,
a test vehicle that his brother had
designed that was not FDA approved and we
were doing aerobatic maneuvers. And this
plane, I mean inside the plane it said,
warning, this airplane is
not FDA approved. And then
Dick Rutan wrote under it.
That's what makes it so fun.
Cool.
Other questions from the uh,
we here, we got one back here.
I love all this great science
programming that I'm starting to see.
I the 12 year old daughter who was really
into science and so we used to love
things like mythbusters. Oh,
you just discovered the white
rabbit project. Yes. Um,
and then now there's your program and
those two at least are both on Netflix.
So I'm wondering if you're seeing Netflix
is really taking this as a focus area
for them and how's it
been working with them?
It's been amazing working with them and I,
that's my impression too.
I don't have any insider knowledge on
that front, but from what I've seen,
it seems like Netflix is really
investing in science programming.
I been talking to my manager
a little bit about this. I,
it feels as if there's been a reality
TV show bubble that has bursted people.
It's been a completely saturated
market and now people are craving more
educational programming.
Um,
then Netflix I think is answered that
call and they've been investing in these
projects. I hope they continue to
do so. Uh, it's been really great.
And in terms of finding jobs,
so yeah,
I mean we feel that the people who work
in this industry feel the same way.
It feels like there are more opportunities
available now than there have been in
the past even four or
five years. So yeah, it,
it feels like there's going to be even
more educational programming coming
online soon.
Cool.
Great question. So another one
from the virtual sphere is, uh,
you graduated from MIT,
probably going many different directions.
Um, the decision industry
versus science communication.
They're both industries,
but I'm very different than versus
going forward for a corporation.
How did that decision that,
that sort of happened organically
or was it a conscious choice?
Um,
I was looking for jobs and one day I got
an email from a production studio that
like, would you like to be the host
of the outer space TV show? Um,
and I was like, yeah, that sounds
cool. And so that's honestly,
that's how that started.
That's how that began.
I had never tried to be
the host of a TV show.
I had never professionally
done science communication.
I did a lot of outreach and that's
how they found me is I had, um,
I had spoken about the benefits of
NASA and the value of NASA, uh, to,
to public audiences before. And there was
stuff on youtube of me doing that. Um,
and I really liked that.
I think if I weren't doing
science communication on
TV because of my masters in
technology and policy,
I would have wanted to work at it on
the hill for maybe the office of Science
and technology policy influencing
science related policy.
So I was already going that routes
that sort of non technical routes,
but working with science and technology.
And then that came along and it
sounded like a really cool adventure.
And now that's just become my career.
Cool.
The question about colonizing Mars.
So there's a lot of uh, you know,
talks about colonizing Mars.
I wonder if you think it's a one way
trip given that it's a very expensive
taking people there is going to
spend some time like in the trip, uh,
ms specialist living there for awhile,
then coming back to earth will
be a problem because first, uh,
I imagine like a bodybuilder
and Mars is going to be like a,
just a regular person here are weaker.
I Dunno.
So how feasible is all
that now people talk about,
yeah,
so I will say that I think the only
way to go to Mars is going to be with
government funding and that NASA would
never allow a one way trip to Mars.
So I think in general they will
figure out how to do a round trip.
People argue that the
technology is already there.
It's just making better technology
to make it more cost effective.
For example,
the,
one of the problems right now is the
radiation that astronauts would experience
on the way to Mars by some calculations.
And an astronaut would definitely have
cancer by the time that they got to Mars
or by the time that they were returning,
um, just because of that radiation.
But what you could do is literally fill
a space ship with a foot of water of
simply h two o, um, and that
would solve the problem,
but that is extremely expensive
and that can be really, uh,
fuel and efficient and propelling an,
uh,
an astronaut group to Mars. So there's
technologies that are out there that are,
could be simple, but it's not really
cost effective. But anyways, I,
long story short, it will eventually,
I'm sure it will be a round trip.
I can't imagine anyone participating in
a one way trip to Mars or funding a one
way trip to Mars. Cool. We had a
question right behind you there. Um,
do you want to go? Oh, definitely not.
No. No. I'm don't even like camping.
So that's, yeah, Mars is definitely
extreme camp. Can we talk about, so one,
have you guys heard of Mars One? You
guys have heard of this? So this was,
this was a big,
uh,
I don't want to say gimmick because I
think they were very sincere and their,
and their ideas,
but they didn't have the technology
to really describe their mission
thoughtfully. But they put out a
request for proposals for, you know,
people who would sign up for a one
way trip to Mars and they got 200,000
applications.
And I saw that and I was like,
I would bet my firstborn child that
half of you have never wanted to go to
Antarctica. Half of you have never even
thought about climbing Mount Everest.
And probably many of you are like
me and don't even like camping.
Like Mars is a terrible planet to live on.
I don't think people really
understand the full ramifications of,
of going there Starbucks to very light.
There's not many there.
So there's a lot of talk today about how
we now live in this post truth world.
Does that change the strategy
for you as a stem educator? Is,
is there some context there?
We have to communicate differently if
facts may be don't mean what they used to.
Yeah.
My strategy with that and I think that
there's always been some hesitancy to
believe experts or there there's,
there's distrust of the scientific
community and there has been for a while.
I think it's, I don't know if
it's growing, it's, it's uh,
a hard under a situation to understand.
But for me,
the way that I address it is I always
tell people you are the most influential
in your own circle of family and friends.
And the most effective way to combat,
uh,
stem illiteracy is to speak to the
people who care about your opinion and to
have those hard conversations
about climate change or
about whatever topic that
you find interesting and
personally care about. Cause they,
you are the person that they are
most likely to listen to. Cool
Tech. I feel like we, uh,
at least in software development we get
to kind of stay as far away from the
government as we possibly
can unless we have to.
Like we'll do the bare minimum to interact
because it's just generally a very
slow, uh, institution.
I feel like in space exploration,
working with the government
is at least half of it.
So it's certainly not just about
science and math and technology.
It is half about like policy makers.
So we'd love to hear your thoughts about
what it's like working a little bit
more with policy makers,
like how you navigate some of that
bureaucracy and not nepotism, but like,
you know,
uh,
short term goals that a
lot of policymakers have.
Yeah, I mean, so I don't personally
work with the government, but you know,
through my show I speak with
NASA who often does. And, um,
what I think that the trade off there
is that for people who work at NASA,
it's, it's very annoying to
deal with that bureaucracy.
It's annoying to deal
with those restrictions.
But at the same time they are working
on some of the most profound questions
humans have ever asked. Like, where
did we come from and are we alone?
And so they get to work on some of the
most exciting projects that any engineer
could help to work on.
Um,
but they are working
under a government salary.
They're not getting paid as much as
they would if they were in industry. Uh,
and then they have to deal with all
the red tape and the bureaucracy.
So I don't know that that
answers your question, but it's,
if you're in the space industry
and you're working for NASA,
you get to do some really incredible
work and really exciting projects.
But there's, you know, there's
a give and take to that.
So I just want to close with one question
since it's the end of the year and
it's always good to end positive.
So what's the,
what of all the things that are happening
right now in space exploration or
science in general that has you most
positive, enthusiastic, optimistic?
Yeah,
I think the fact that people like ending
this is a very specific technology that
I'm excited about,
but blue origin and space x working to
perfect reusable rockets is just changing
the game in the space industry.
I mean,
Elon Musk thinks that he can take
that $30 billion price tag with,
with Mars.
Um,
and that would equate to
about a $10 billion ticket
for sending a person to Mars
today to a $200,000 ticket to sending a
person to March today because of rocket
reusability.
And so I think that once that's
perfected and proven to be safe,
it's going to completely change our
mindset on going to Mars and expanding the
human race into the solar system.
Cool.
Thank you very much for those virtually
avoiding the rain and those in the room.
Thank you, Emily, for sure.
Thoughts. Really appreciate
it. Thank you. Thank you.